[Applause]
the mentors video blew up i see you
really like the video so why not have a
slightly expanded continuation of it so
for today we'll have a second volume of
mentors showing off their power in front
of their pupils so expect some of the
previous mentors showing their chomps
here because as we all know the most
badass mentors don't just confine
themselves to one crowning moment of
glory i don't think this needs a longer
introduction so let's get on with the
show starting off this list is guy
versus madara
mostly presented as a goofy mentor for
comedic purposes guy decided that enough
is enough and engages moderate in one of
my favorite scenes from this war arc
we've heard a lot of hype for the eight
gates but we've never actually seen it
in action well this badass mentor
demonstrates it opening all eight gates
at once guy transforms and engages
madana in direct combat yes the madonna
that just plowed through an entire army
the same mother who effortlessly beat
the kangas in a flex moment of his own
and he more than holds his own
unleashing the deadly technique and
forcing freaking madonna himself to
acknowledge his strength it's not even a
hot take to say that without plot armor
guy could have taken down madara he came
really really close to it and he's the
first one who managed to deal that much
damage to the supposedly invincible
villain a crowning moment right at the
end you'd love to see it
yep i've been looking to talk about lisa
lisa for a while now remember this
moment from battle tendency wyatt beck
had one job prevent joseph and lisa lisa
from reaching his master cars and he did
a pretty good job at it for a while
admittedly joseph found himself
absolutely dumbfounded at wyatt beck's
powers but when it's the mentor's turn
it's all over in what little screen time
wyatt beck had at least he did a great
job in putting lisa lisa over and
showing the world how badass of a mentor
she was it's a complete squash but hey
this guy made the most of what little
time he had
we move on to gojo's hollow purple
so often i talk about what amazing arc
ending battle yuji and aawi versus
hanami was heck it made its mark in the
anime community and it's rightfully
featured in a lot of my lists however
what often gets left out or given less
focus was the ending of it all you see
the duo alone didn't defeat the special
grade curse even with their combined
strength they weren't able to finish the
job and i bet if that things went on
they'd find themselves in big trouble
luckily op mentor gojo is here to once
again steal the show before we talked
about him flexing against jojo and
treating a supposed life and death
battle as a tutorial for yuji out of all
things now it's time for him to go all
out once again and that he did showing
off hollow purple the actual
presentation of the technique gave it
all the hype it needed and if there's
any doubt on its destructive capability
just look at what it did to the
surroundings and how it one-shotted the
recovering hanami yay
opening up share and subscribe if you've
been liking what you've seen so far and
let's hit that magic 1 million
subscriber number by the middle of the
year only you can make it happen and i
know you can do it so i'm counting on
you
sometimes the most badass moments come
from the most unexpected places not to
say that izumi was never established as
a badass she is one and she trained the
l rig brothers in alchemy all that
despite her disdain towards stay
alchemists and her favor of physical
prowess this attitude is probably what
caught me off guard when she comes in
for the big save when the elrics find
themselves in trouble against greed
calling herself as nothing more than a
lowly housewife she lays the smackdown
on greed completely rocking him in her
dynamic entrance much to greed and ed's
surprise of course it's not enough to do
greed in but we all know she made a big
big impression with that entrance most
badass housewife slash mom indeed anyone
who dares touch the oryx beware
what better way to make an impression on
your future pupil than to be that one
shining beacon of hope amid certain doom
a young kenshin finds his life saved by
the strongest swordsman who would become
his future mentor the one and only hiko
seijuro well he damn sure made one big
first impression on this boy he saved
from bandits and how can he not be
kenshin was staring death in the eye and
out of nowhere this powerful swordsman
just comes out and solos all these
rogues who killed his companions it's
not quite as cinematic as other one-man
army moments i've talked about but it
gets the job done as far as we're
concerned this was the beginning of a
legend and it was all possible thanks to
hiko showing his might in the face of
his
[Music]
pupil we go to one piece for our next
moment
with how prominent of an ability haki is
now it feels good to take a look back at
its humble beginnings when it was first
introduced in the perspective of the
main character and this is the moment
when rayleigh showcases the different
types of haki do you love interactive
tutorials i certainly do and this feels
like a precursor to the previous lists
gojo moment right this time it's the
elephant who's the training dummy and
rayleigh just teaching luffy about haki
while the beast tries its darnest to hit
him is nothing short of flex overall i
also like this moment because it makes
sense of some previous moments like the
monster backing down against shanks
that's good storytelling right there
yami makes his list return with death
thrust
as black clover winds down towards its
end it never forgot to give us one more
banash yummy moment to enjoy as if
showing off to the black balls in the
moment from the previous list wasn't
enough he had to come in and save the
squad once more this time against the
seemingly unstoppable dante dante just
finished soloing the black balls but it
only served as a prelude to the main
event the titanic showdown between
heavyweights yami and dante traded blow
after blow with it culminating with yami
putting out one of his most badass
attacks of all time death thrust the
ominous looking attack had all it needed
to make an impact both in and out of
universe it also completely obliterated
dante despite all of the latters
boasting the fight's not over and arster
soon joins the battle but this is
definitely another mentor safe to
remember
[Music]
which amongst all these moments is your
favorite tell everyone on the comments
section below we'd like to hear your
thoughts on
algorithm
anyway we here at vini tube would be
glad to have you as part of our growing
communities discord instagram patreon if
you have any of those make sure to join
our channels on the description box and
have fun with the team and fellow anime
fans once again thank you for watching
and for all of the support i hope you
stay safe and stay strong out there and
i'll be eagerly waiting for you on the
next video
[Music]
you